this is what would happen if you ate a  brick of dry ice you may have actually  eaten this before as it's sometimes in  cocktails and ice cream but that's only  in small doses the real thing is as cold  as minus 78 degrees celsius so as soon  as you ate it you would immediately feel  the cooling sensation all around your  mouth your tongue and mouth would be  frozen in a matter of seconds and your  teeth would feel awful like biting into  the coldest ice cream ever  and if you kept it in there longer you'd  eventually get frostbite and after you  swallowed the dry ice it would land in  your stomach if you ate enough dry ice  it would produce a sharp pain and you'd  also get frostbite on your stomach  lining the more dry ice you ate it would  turn into a gas and you'd be burping up  this freezing gas  if you continued to eat the dry ice more  gas would accumulate in your stomach  eventually causing it to rupture  yeah don't try this at home so